In this video, we are going to properly
set up and use a balance together.
Before using a balance, you want to make
sure it's properly calibrated.
The way that you calibrate a balance
is with pre calibrated weight standards.
They look like this.
Now you want to make sure that the balance
has been plugged in for
about an hour or two before you start,
the next step is to level the balance.
You do that by turning the dials
on the sides of the balance
to make sure that the bubble
is in the center.
Now it's time to calibrate.
Normally
there's a 'Cal' button on the balance.
Some balances have internal cal,
and that's fine for daily calibration.
For more thorough calibration,
we want to do a spanning cal from here.
The balance will prompt you to place
pre calibrated weight standards.
Place the weights when prompted
and store the values when you're done.
You can now use the balance
when there's nothing on the balance,
you use '0' to zero everything out.
'Tare' is not zero.
Tare is only used
when something is on the balance
and you want to remove the weight of that
something.
Use tare when you want to weigh
something in something.
Pretty simplistic, but you'd be surprised
how many people get that wrong.
There you have it.
That's how you set up
and properly use a balance.
If you want us to keep making more videos
to help make your life in the lab easier.
Like and subscribe.